what up space fam golson here from anime
opera and i'm back at it again to
discuss the latest and craziest updates
in the one piece story today we got a
lot of exciting and insane developments
concerning sanji and his fight so make
sure to stay tuned for this one if you
do enjoy seeing these one-piece reviews
i want to keep them coming you know what
to do channel the power king within and
smash that like button with no mercy
remember smashing that like button is
power king energy and passing is orochi
energy so choose wisely if you haven't
make this the video you subscribe and
this is crucial hit that notification
bell to turn on all notifications or you
will miss future one piece videos and
updates and lastly while you wait for
the next chapter to drop feel free to
check out my huge in growing one piece
playlist that includes videos in all the
yonko warlords admirals and much more
link to that is in the description and
without further ado let's jump into it
spoilers and all this chapter is
fittingly called sanji vs queen and
zorro and king had a chance to shine
recently so it makes sense we get to see
what sanji's up to this time around
although there's been an understandably
big focus on zorro in the wano arc oda
did not neglect sanji either and his
developments in this arc have been
fascinating as well however before we
get into the fight itself we catch up
with that woman the one sanji apparently
hit that definitely hasn't been
completely explained since sanji didn't
remember a thing it looked bad and fans
even started talking about an evil sanji
but there's definitely some missing
pieces we need to fill in and we do get
them in this chapter which is huge for
now though this girl is so nice she's
thinking about chuji rather than herself
all of this is making the idea of sanji
being cruel to her all the more terrible
then we jump to momo who is still a
dragon and even says he's as much of a
dragon as kaido if need be he comments
that he can grab kaido's flame clouds if
he can't force the island back thus it
looks like he's considering removing
kaido's flame clouds and sending the
island plummeting if he has to since at
least then the people of the flower
capital his people might survive
especially if yamato deals with those
weapons or is doing a great job of
building tension here i can only imagine
how insane this will be in the anime
with all these top tier fights going on
at the same time and in the background
the time limit of the island hitting the
capital is fast approaching this is a
great moment for momo as well as he's
completely manned up here saying this
island will not destroy the flower
capital while i still draw bread this is
a far cry from the crybaby he
understandably used to be after all he
is still very young at least mentally
right now now yeah he's still probably
afraid but he's willing to sacrifice his
life before he abandons his people he's
showing here that he's truly a great
leader now we rejoin the fight between
queen and sanji suddenly queen starts
launching attacks that sanji's brothers
use we got laser beams from the eyes the
electricity that accompanies the move
henry blazer an amazing name for a move
by the way and so on queen laughs at our
blonde cook saying he wanted to show
sanji all those moves after he used the
suit to morph as we could have guessed
he views judges sons as the combination
of judge's scientific work he wanted
sanji to put the suit on so bad so he
could beat the combination of judge's
science and prove he's the better
fighter and more importantly i think for
queen the better scientist he clearly
has an intense rivalry with the judge
wishing that he could have shown him
once and for all that judge's technology
can't hold a candle to queen's own
technology and while queen is in his own
world attributing all of this meaning to
this battle sanji simply says it has
nothing to do with him as we know sanji
doesn't want to be connected to judge so
everything queen's saying literally
means nothing to him if anything it just
makes him angry i think it's hilarious
how they're on completely different
pages here if sanji beats queen now
queen might attribute it to judge's
technology instead of to sanji as an
individual which would no doubt be very
annoying to sanji however hopefully by
the time the battle is over sanji will
be able to make queen take him seriously
as an individual for now though queen
looks to be in the lead and controlling
the temple of the fight he says he was
playing dumb earlier and in reality he
dug up everything there is to know about
germa's science or at least he thinks he
did he insists that his arsenal can
replicate anything the brothers can do
thinking that it all boils down to
science and technology however as we
know in one piece individual will is
huge and overlooking that in this case
sanji's individual will will no doubt
lead the queen's downfall as queen is
pummeling sanji sanji kicks through his
mechanical arm breaking it queen is
clearly surprised and upset calling
sanji a dirty brat a beat up sanji then
gets up and says he warned queen about
mentioning judge and the others in front
of him you know things are gonna get
crazy right about now with sanji
bringing up his prior warning queen is
like you think you can control what i
say and sanji answers that question with
a kick i love seeing how composed
sanji's stances look in between kicks he
looks so light on his feet which is a
great contrast to the clearly heavy and
overweight queen and at this point you
could tell that sanji's attacks are
clearly delivering some real pain to
queen it's at this point sanji mentions
that the difference between them is
their resolve not science or technology
sanji has accepted his fate and as a
result he's not the same man queen
fought on the live floor then we
shouldn't be surprised but it's still
pretty crazy to see queen activates
invisibility a power we know well from
sanji's suit queen is taunting him
saying alright show me how you've
changed this is such a great fight for
sanji because we know he has had issues
with his family and queen takes all of
their powers and combines them within
himself thus he can serve as the perfect
symbolic outlet for sanji to take out
his frustrations about his family credit
goes to oda for how well thought out his
matchups are it's not just about
relative strength levels they're well
constructed thematically as well anyways
back to the fight and sanji disappears
to queen's shock queen decides it's
because he's moving faster than the eye
can see so he'll just wait until sanji
runs out of stamina at this point we see
a mouse running into the battlefield and
this mouse is the chuji that the lady
was looking for she's chased him here
and we finally get the answers that
we've been looking for queen recognizes
her as osome the lady that refused his
summons not once or twice but dozens of
times wow that is a lot of rejections he
says she even refused him today even
though she seems fine according to him
queen clearly upset by all her
rejections says he guesses he hasn't
dished out enough divine punishment yet
and tells her to have some more as his
invisible self moves in to hurt her
before he can do it though sanji steps
in he comments on his exoskeleton
enhanced strength and speed he'll use
them all to improve his attack his
exoskeleton paired with his armament
haki training means his legs should be
able to withstand way hotter flames than
before the increased heat is combined
with increased speed and weight behind
the kick and so its attack will be on a
whole other level that's the science
behind this new powerful attack there's
also an emotional element too though
sanji realizes that it was queen using
his invisibility who hit the woman
before not sanji this explains why queen
told her to have some more before his
attack implying he already dished out
some of his so-called divine punishment
to her now sanji captures that rage he's
feeling towards someone who would hit a
woman like osume and channels it into
the attack as well he calls queen trash
as the physical and emotional
ingredients are there for an ultra
powerful attack he lands the attack
bringing queen no longer invisible down
to the ground i love how he just knocks
the invisibility right out of him osume
is shocked to see queen suddenly show up
and sanji continues with the merciless
attacks kick after kick after kick and
so on it's such a satisfying sequence of
attacks because in a way it's like he's
taking out all of his frustrations about
his family about being blackmailed about
queen's own sickening behavior and
channeling it into the onslaught of
kicks combine that with his new physical
power up and you get such an epic moment
sanji is a monster no doubt but not an
evil monster the last panel finishes
with what looks like a definitive kick
and queen blasts off like team rocket
let me know do you think that the fight
is over i would totally be satisfied if
this was the end here sanji's name was
cleared the one responsible was punished
we got to see sanji's power up and yeah
i don't know what else i'd want to see
from this fight i think oda pretty much
covered it all as always let me know
what you thought of this chapter and who
your mvp was i think sanji is the pretty
obvious choice here he was amazing this
chapter there's absolutely no doubt
about that if you did enjoy this review
and want to keep them coming you know
what to do channel the pyroking within
and smash that like button with no mercy
remember smashing that like button is
pyroking energy and passing is orochi
energy so choose wisely if you haven't
make this the video you subscribe and
hit that notification bell to turn on
all notifications or you will miss
future one piece videos and updates and
lastly while you wait for the next
chapter to drop feel free to check out
my huge and growing one piece playlist
that includes videos on the yonko
warlords supernovas admirals and much
more link to that is in the description
and i especially want to thank the
patron squad over on patreon and here on
youtube who helped make videos like this
one possible first and foremost i want
to thank the patron of legend the one
acknowledged by lord wigo himself alpha
sigma and other one tier patrons the
ones who stay on top all clans ingrata
al jatal pate hepa the red haired fox
hinokami and water the toasted chi corey
mcgowan the spike lonely dakar dylan
isadore spidey life tinel tungsten
tarkis big buddhist jeremy cummings and
che a whitley and our pro hero tier
patrons the one and only gilgamesh
steelers angel crews very gucci alicia
actor bonnie parks joanne garcia fat boy
games kind of might be a duck jessica
rabbit jeremy phillips ali baitnia and
temple thank you all so much if you do
enjoy our work you can support more of
it by going over to patreon.com animepor
and becoming a patron today for as
little as one dollar if you do so the
gear name feature in future videos
alongside these amazing people right
here and you'll even get access to our
private patron only discord where we
talk about anime life and of course
thank meme so check out
patreon.com link in the description if
you're interested you can also join the
youtube channel by clicking that blue
join button next to the subscribe button
that you've hopefully already destroyed
so yeah you can support more content
that way if you prefer whichever way you
support us you can get the same great
benefits thanks again and until next
time see you space cowboys
[Music]
you